all right let's go back now to our top
story and the unrest in Sudan we can
speak now to Dr Alden who's a spokesman
of the Sudanese professionals
Association joins us now from Khartoum
sir just give us the very latest on the
situation where you are what's happening
with the fighting is it quietly done
yeah the fighting uh escalating uh in
cartoon in other states unfortunately
and they're still throughout the last
night there is a lot of bombing in the
three cities especially in Durban in the
north from German where it is the
biggest military
presence and the Military College and so
on in the south of Wonderland also uh
near to the
to the headquarter of the medical
military areas
that's uh that's uh that's it it is
collecting throughout the night and also
outside in the states uh in also in the
in the south in the Blue Nile States in
in castella
so the gun the gunfire or the bombing is
escalating the situation between the
rapid support forces and the Army all
right
60 and 600 600 injured people indeed so
as things are escalating what what about
daily life uh within the city in terms
of you know electricity supplies and so
forth
there are many places there is shut down
of the electricity and there's no water
supply in many places in many
neighborhoods in the in Khartoum the
capital whether in Khartoum North Bahari
or on durman or
many of the people are complaining of
the shutdown of the electricity and the
water supply
is it safe to go outside staying in the
houses
excuse me is it safe to go outside
no no it's not safe at home to go
outside
even even the doctors cannot read the
hospitals I don't reach the hospital
and what about getting food supplies and
Water Supplies
even even the ambulance even the
ambulance cannot move in the streets but
it's a very big mess uh it's something
that's horrible really what's happening
right now in Sudan and khatum and we say
it in the FFC and the spa we said that
that the the political process is the
way to get the country out but nobody
was listening the the previous Muslim
Brotherhood are waiting for this
situation that's happening right now
they wear they have a media campaign for
this to happen for this war to happen
between the rsf and the Army and they
succeeded at the end of the day
so what do you think can be done to try
and resolve this situation
I think that the the efforts should
continue between the
to talk between the two generals to stop
to ceasefire the international pressure
should continue uh for that
and the most important thing that the
Muslim Brotherhood should be pinpointed
that they are the cause of this and they
are the only benefit uh beneficial body
from what's happening right now and
there and this was what they are
planning for uh for a long time since
the framework agreements and the final
particle process started that Muslim
Brotherhood are behind this and they
have some people in the in the military
and they have some people in there in
the security forces who are like making
the atmosphere uh favorable for uh
gunfire and for the war so I think uh
their trial to come back to the show and
to come back to ruling uh is the cause
behind all this
well both sides of course have their
arguments as we'll discover as the day
goes on but for the time being thanks
very much indeed Dr
thanks very much